was the film what you imagined it would
be after being out there for a week and
looking at all this footage year after
year
uh
it's tough it's tough it's like it's
like we
took boxes of puzzles and we took all
the boxes and put them in
it's like oh man how do you sort back
out to the the right puzzles here but
ultimately we made a we made a film from
several different puzzle boxes
and and i think it works uh ultimately
our film is like a real time film so
monday through sunday this is what
happened
uh there's all these cameras and all
these cameras were sorted by time order
and our documentary is basically exactly
what happened in the sequence that
happened out there
from all these different perspectives
which is just a fascinating thing to me
to see like the comparison the contrast
of like okay at one moment on the playa
someone is admiring artwork in deep
playa just out there blissed out amazing
artwork at the exact same moment
someone's in an rv
um dealing with what it means to to not
be loved by another person and and
you know is that a lesson that you have
to go through
you know are you comfortable enough with
yourself
you know these it's so it was just this
fascinating
way that it came together and i think
you know our film is a perfect example
of filmmaking kind of being a carving of
marble or you're like chipping away at
like what doesn't need to be there so
yeah
we threw out you know
429 hours of the 430 and like ended up
with this amazing piece of
artwork that's left over from your
original block i kind of look at it like
a stick figure because it's really thin
it's just exactly what fits in a 90
minute film
but it's beautiful
it's a beautiful creation and i think i
think the multiple perspectives in the
film really work and i've gotten some
amazing feedback recently we just had a
review yesterday go up um
basically about how
it's like the true experience or at
least a version of the true experience
about going out there and
you know because it is it is sort of
like what is the experience out there
how do you show what it is like
from the perspective of someone
experiencing that and i think we've
we've totally captured that